I have what we call a few fun questions
and I will find out if you like them or
not in about 30 seconds
who ruined the most takes Hobbs our Shah
uh hubs because he's very unsure of
himself who is most likely to get it on
the first take Hobbes or Shah sure
always who was a better wingman
Hobbs or Shawn I was never a wingman who
was faster at leaving their trailer
Hobbs or Shawn sure every day I've got
many people can prove that who has more
hair Hobbs or shop I don't know each ins
not very hairy so I'll have to say maybe
me okay who is better on a date Hobbs or
Shawn Hey but sure provide the romantic
sort of moments that most ladies would
like who is faster at learning their
lines
Hobbs our Shawn I just come in on the
day and learn them so it's pretty easy
for me yesterday you know go home with
the Bible need some way in advance
um this is now gonna be some fight
questions who wins in a fight Hobson
Shaw or Jason boring Hobbs is sure
clearly okay abs in Shaw or Deadpool
look it's hard to beat Hobbs ensure
we're you know as much as we don't like
each other we're pretty puts together we
can take the head off most people I'm
gonna get this I think the no one the
next one could be a tougher one
Hobbs in Shaw or John wick Joe we ain't
got a sniffling Hobbs is sure sorry
pubs in Shaw or John McClane in die hard
they're all gonna have to take a
backseat really said there's no hold on
ladies Hobson sure you're talking about
I understand the next one is the
Terminator
I love Arnold but Hobson sure will take
his little robot head off okay
Hobbes in Shaw or a Fanus from Avengers
end game they ain't got two minutes to
even think about taking me and Dwayne oh
okay Hobson sure it right I'm gonna see
if there's clearly I'm not gonna Sarah
Connor in Terminator 2 I love Sarah
Connor but she's come to the party for
us
Liam Neeson and taken he will have to be
taken to the hospital if he fights
Hobson sure what about Chev Chelios
Chev Chelios now that's a different man
Hobbs will have to go hospital wait so
they're so champions I can win this one
know him very well so he's finally have
a winner it be sure sure and jealous the
new duo
what about Bruce Lee and Enter the
Dragon oh god he's my ultimate hero I'd
have to give it to Bruce I finally found
a winner okay um Indiana Jones no Jones
Wolverine no hope
Sigourney Weaver is Ripley an aliens I
love Sigourney Weaver but it's do you
have okay I'm gonna switch subject yeah
yeah absolutely serious do you have a
favorite we're not one of the things I
love about the franchise The Fast and
Furious franchise ant hubs in Shaw is it
these movies know what they are and they
have a lot of fun and there's a lot of
fun over-the-top moments yeah do you
have a favorite of all the over-the-top
moments in these movies I do I have my
favorite is the McLaren car chase
because you know the fact that most
people don't know about that is Dwayne
Johnson has motion sickness so anything
over 30 miles an hour they have the CG
him into that scene people think he's in
the McLaren but really is not we had him
in the car or try to get him in the car
we had to butter his hips to get him in
the seat couldn't quite get in there and
then I said look we're gonna be going
over 30 miles an hour you might want to
take one of your motion sickness pills
you may know that I'll just be in my
trailer so that was a CG moment that me
and you know Vanessa Kirby had some fun
right um I while I loved the action in
this movie I think actually my favorite
stuff is new and Dwayne insulting each
other I love these scenes they're
fantastic yeah yeah how much what does
it like filming those things and how
much is all of that completely scripted
and how much you coming up with
even more onset we come up with a lot on
set and I guess it's part of the fun of
what Dave the way that Dave Leitch likes
to run the set Duane loves to spit
things out I like to do the same thing
we just bring it on the day we have
obviously a structured sort of a scene
that we can at least get out of jail
with if we need it but those those sort
of moments there's no story to tell it's
just the story is you don't want to work
with him you don't want to work with you
let's sort of recall some of the reasons
for the for the feeling so it's just
literally a tennis match of ping ping
ping ping ping and then how do we get
out of the scene so it's it's it's a lot
of fun to shoot those things because
they don't have to tell the story the
story is what do I know about you this
is what I know about you therefore you
ain't working with me and then it goes
over to him oh right you don't like this
you don't like that I know there's
always it you know an odd sort of mum
insult and then it gets very personal
and then oops and then we can sort of
you know we can get we can bring it to a
conclusion